it is hard to overstate the beneficial
effects of immunization according to the
US Centers for Disease Control US
children born over the last 20 years for
those children vaccines will prevent
greater than 322 million illnesses
greater than 21 million hospitalizations
and greater than seven hundred and
thirty thousand deaths with the societal
cost savings of nearly one point four
trillion dollars those are big numbers
but let's zoom in and look at a
particular example vaccines have nearly
eliminated a bacterial infection called
hemolysis influenza this bacterium used
to infect young infants causing
bloodstream infections pneumonia
meningitis death or permanent disability
as a young pediatrician I saw a few
cases you folks probably have never
heard of this disease because vaccines
have been so effective you could see in
the graph on the right that since the
introduction of vaccines the incidence
of Hamas Phylis bacterial infections has
plummeted like a rock and it's nearly
vanished
so vaccines are generally a success
story but we also face challenges for
one for most vaccines we need to give
multiple doses to achieve or maintain
protection the scientific community is
working on developing single shot
vaccines imagine being able to get only
one influenza shot your whole life and
not having to get a seasonal flu vaccine
for certain microbes they're difficult
to immunize against a classic example is
human immunodeficiency virus or HIV the
need is urgent progress is being made
we're not there yet another critical
element in vaccine research right now is
optimizing vaccines for the most
vulnerable among us the very young and
the elderly and this is an active area
of research
finally one of the biggest challenges we
unfortunately face right now are anti
VAX attitudes in fact it's alarming that
over 100,000 infants and children in the
United States have not received any
vaccines and that number is growing in
fact the World Health Organization or
w-h-o has declared anti-vaxxer a tude as
one of the 10 most important threats to
human health in the world today this
graphic illustrates the spread of anti
vaccine t'me in the state of California
from the year 2000 to 2013 by looking at
the percentage of public kindergarten
students who claim the personal
exemption against immunization antov
accent iment is on the rise and it has
very real consequences many of you may
be aware of the fact that we're seeing
infections that we thought we conquered
long ago coming back measles outbreaks
have been reported in multiple US states
and many have forgotten but measles is
very infectious and dangerous just a few
viral particles can infect an individual
and there have been even reports at
sporting events in an Olympic Stadium
where the virus through the air travels
long distances and if infects a
vulnerable person in the crowd in fact
if I had a measles coughed right now
somebody in the back of this auditorium
could get infected and and this has had
very real-world consequences just a few
months ago an airline stewardess
contracted measles on a flight the virus
entered her brain and caused in careful
itis and she died so people are now
dying due to this ant Eve accent iment I
do want to take a few minutes to address
those who don't believe in vaccines and
who resist vaccines as a pediatrician
who receives my yearly flu vaccination
as a parent of three three children who
have been vaccinated according to the
recommended schedule and as a pediatric
infectious disease consultant who's
taken care of young children with
meningitis that would have been
preventable had their parent
accepted immunization this is a personal
matter to me let's take a look at who is
going to pay the price if we start
dialing back the amount of vaccinations
in our society this graph depicts on the
y-axis the number of individuals dying
of infection in the world and on the
x-axis the age of the individuals who
are dying and as you can see it's very
much a u-shaped distribution and it's
particularly stark in the very young
ages so vaccines shield the very young
from infection and if we want to talk my
friends about what vaccines cause
because there's a lot of speculation
unfounded speculation on the internet of
what vaccines cause vaccines cause
adults okay that's what they cause and
the other thing that they cause is for
elderly individuals to live longer
because they are shielded against
influenza and other killers of the
elderly now let's talk a little bit
about how we can improve vaccines even
further we can create vaccines that can
immunize the most vulnerable among us
and perhaps even vaccines that protect
with single shots let me go over a
little bit of the immunology in the top
panel what you see is a simple vaccine
all vaccines contain something called an
antigen the antigen is like a piece of a
germ of a microbe that your body
remembers right it forms antibodies and
those antibodies can protect you so
those kind of vaccines can induce an
immune response but as you see here that
immune response tends to go up and back
down and you need to get another dose
and another dose to maintain protection
what can we do we and other scientists
around the world are finding molecules
that can boost a vaccine response those
are called adjuvants from the Latin ad
revoir to help or aid adjuvants are
molecules we might add to a vaccine to
get a stronger response and in the
presence of the adjuvant depicted here
in red you have a much more profound
activation of the white blood cells of
your immune system and generate a much
more profound immune response with much
higher antibody levels more rapidly and
that lasts a long time for durable
immunity interestingly
these adjuvant have different effects
depending on the age or other
demographic factors of the individual
which brings me to the notion of
precision vaccines this is the idea that
we will take precision medicine you know
what precision medicine is right that's
the idea that populations may vary in
their response to a particular medicine
and apply that to vaccines right and
here in Boston Children's Hospital at
the precision vaccines program I direct
we have five approaches stepwise
approaches we take to build precision
vaccines that are tailored to vulnerable
populations number one we need to
understand what the attitude of a given
population is towards a vaccine you
could build the most sophisticated
vaccine in the world but if nobody wants
to take it you're going nowhere number
two we have to think of the route of
immunization most vaccines are
intramuscular or i.m but there are
others in for nasal oral and others then
as I just described to you vaccines have
components all vaccines have an antigen
that's the part of the microbe that your
body remembers that you might make
antibodies or cell mediated immunity
against and we might add an adjuvant as
we talked about to boost an immune
response but guess what there are many
different antigens to choose from and
many different advents how are we going
to make that decision and the menu of
these keeps growing so on our team we've
developed ways to test vaccines outside
the body in Latin that's in vitro in a
tissue culture dish so we use tissue
engineering with blood cells to immunize
outside the body and study the effect of
the vaccine against for example infants
or elderly individuals or others and if
you think about it this is critical
because if you look at all the
infections we want to build vaccines
against like Zika virus and Ebola virus
and HIV and others all the candidate
antigens all the candidate adjuvants all
the different populations it's going to
be impossible to do large phase 3
clinical trials for every combination
this is where we think being able to
test vaccines outside the body can make
a big difference to accelerate vaccine
development
and finally this whole effort is to
drive an immune response that will
protect against that particular pathogen
getting antibodies and other cells to
defend the body we are also using
additional innovative approaches to
bring the most cutting-edge science to
vaccine development we're taking a
deeper dive as to how current vaccines
protect we've formed an international
consortium to study how hepatitis B
vaccine protects newborns from hepatitis
B infection and to do this we've
developed a technique called small
sample big data we can get a tiny little
drop of baby blood before immunization
and take a tiny little drop after
immunization and we can measure the
inventory of all the cells in all the
genes and all the molecules in that drop
of blood and we can compare after the
vaccine to before the vaccine in that
same baby and understand in a deep way
exactly how that successful vaccine
protects in those lessons we can use to
build the next vaccines in the future so
this diagram is really illustrating a
tiny dappled blood yielding huge amounts
of information tens of thousands of
analytes and that hairball is meant to
depict the gene pathways that are turned
on and the molecular pathways that are
turned on so much more to come on that
and very exciting science so we are
partnering with scientists around the
world to bring all these new
technologies to invigorate vaccine
development in a precision vaccines
network we are going to advance
personalized vaccines for vulnerable
populations around the world and our
team includes scientists technical
experts and physicians and we're
developing vaccines against infectious
diseases like pertussis which is
whooping cough we have a whooping cough
vaccine but it requires multiple doses
and the immunity keeps dropping we want
to develop a single shot pertussis
vaccine we're working on a vaccine for
respiratory syncytial virus the number
one cause of infant hospitalization in
the United States of a better vaccine
against influenza and of course HIV
we're also looking at vaccines against
cancer allergy and interestingly opioid
overdose
so this is my final message to you
vaccines protect you and your loved ones
and the people around you not only do
they protect you against infection they
do prevent you from spreading it to
others get immunized the scientific
progress is fragile and can be lost
we must foster accurate and respectful
public dialogue and finally we're on the
verge of great things a new era of
vaccination we've just scratched the
surface of what can be accomplished
please advocate for this research thank
you